[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الحقيقه الهوايه بدات معاه في التسعينات
اولا التسعينات
كنت في المدرسه
كنت بربي العصافير التربيه البدائيه كان
عندي قفص تربيه جماعيه الطير كله بيتوالى
سوا بيتربى سوا قاعد فعلا شجره وبعد كده
كانت الانواع حتى بسيطه كان في ثلاثه
انواع بالنسبه للطياره البادجي كان في
باندل وفي الهراكل اللي هو وفي البلديه
[موسيقى]
في حاجه من المواليد فيها مثلا
خشم مقفول كله ماكل كويس لو في حاجه ما
ماكله بتستحق
اؤك لنا مثلا الحاجات اللي ما عندها
مواليد ما بالطراف تحصن باراجع من بره بس
اشوف الاكل اشوف كذا حاجات بسيطه وانا
ماشي على على السرعه كده واراجع يعني اذا
في
ملحوظات بسيطه بعملها غير كده كله تمام
بطلع بعدها شغل يعني
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله ما بحتاج لدكتور يعني اخدت خبره
طويله
فقدرت بقدر افرز يعني لو كانت الوساخه
بتاعه الطائر حمراء ديكورديا لو كانت
خضراء
لو كانت بيضه ودي ايكولايس فكل حاجه
عرفتها تنفسيات لو عنده تنفسيه بعرفها في
الطاير الجو مهم جدا يعني الجو الطيور
داري جو محتدل 27 الى 28 اللي هو الجو
العادي انا عندي مقياس بتاع حراره بجيبه
من الصيدليه بجسلين رطوبه وبقي درجه
الحراره
فلو لقيت زادت من 28 انا بقوم بفتح
التكييف بتاع طوالي لقيتها اقل من 26 فهي
مقبوله لحد 16 مقبوله
[موسيقى]
عندي حاجات انا انتجتها ما موجوده في
العالم كله دي بتديك يعني زي براءه
الانتاج الطائر الوحيد في العالم اللي هو
رينبو هاجروم انجليزي ده عندي انا الحمد
لله وده من انتاجي بعد 9 سنه من المجهود
ومن الادخار ومن التزاوج المستمر ونقل
الطفره عبر جيناتا من من بايرلي طائر ومن
حجم لحجمه وكل ما مر انا بشيل معي حاجه
لقدام فمجرد ما تجي سيره الطفره بتاعت
الرينبو معروف ان يصطاير بقى موجود في
السودان عند المربي وليد المساوي
[موسيقى]
الببغاوات دي بدت معي ما طولت لها زي
ثلاثه سنين
بتعجبني الفكره بتاعه انه حتى انا ما مفكر
انتجه لكن بتعجبني الفكره بانه تكون مدلله
وهي اكشف معي تعشيلها تاكل من يدك تشرب
تطلع في كتفك تلعب مع اولادك فهي عندها
نوح كده بتاع مرح وحاجات شخصيه اكثر من
الطيور يعني انت قادر اجتهادك تعلم الكلام
اسامي اولادك ترد عليك ترقص تغني كده
[موسيقى]
انت بتبداك هوايه بتنتج منها بتفرق منها
في يومك بكون عندك ضغوطات عمل بيكون في
عطلات بتقعد مع هوايتك بتفرق نفسك شويه
بتمرق من الدنسنه بتاعه الشوارع والموت
بتبقى مع الطيور دي وبساطتها
وانتاجك يعني
[موسيقى]